[Music]
so far
very few children have become seriously
ill with covid19 to the point of being
hospitalized
about a third of them have a
pre-existing condition made worse by
covid such as a lung disease
the other two thirds are premature
babies or children with down syndrome
anderson's cove to infection can also
trigger the so-called pediatric
inflammatory multisystem syndrome
or pims a disease that attacks various
organs in children
whether they have severe mild or even no
covet symptoms at
all which makes you wonder shouldn't
children be higher up on the priority
list
in fighting the pandemic
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
now we all tend to associate old age
with frailty and illness right
so when it comes to prioritizing kovid
19 vaccination
we all say the old and vulnerable should
come first
but what about the young and vulnerable
here's the struggle of a family that
feels abandoned by society
is a loving partner to her husband who
has suffered from
[ __ ] paralysis since birth she also
looks after her son felix the family
could really do with some outside help
but that's a risky prospect
in times of covet
it is very difficult for me to weigh it
all up
because if we catch it it will be very
bad
for the boy and for me too
the family has been living in almost
complete isolation for a year
catching covert would most likely be
fatal for the boy and his stepfather
getting vaccinated would change all that
but it's been three months since the
vaccination rollout in germany and the
family is still waiting
right now the pandemic clearly shows
where the rights of the severely
disabled are not exercised or seen at
all
or at which point the u.n disability
rights convention
is once again just on paper
felix shows us his room he suffers from
chronic muscle weakness
so he has to be artificially ventilated
when he sleeps
his mother looks after him around the
clock
every night is a night shift she tells
us
so how is it sleeping with the
ventilator at night is that all right
mostly it's difficult for him to fall
asleep if he gets to sleep then it's not
a problem
for the past year felix has taken all of
his classes online
his parents would like to have him
vaccinated so he can go back to school
once the lockdown is eased
it would be a so-called off-labor
vaccination because the vaccine
has not been approved for children but
sonia kutcher says
they can't find any support for that
either
there's no one out there who says please
contact us now
we
also hopes that the needs of people with
disabilities
will be put in focus more
i hope this interview will make us be
more visible
to everyone
until that happens the family will
continue their struggle
and professor marcus knuff is director
of the clinic for children and
adolescents
at helios dr host schmidt clinic in
wiesbaden good to have you with us
um as a pediatric intensivist or
critical care physician
and infectiologist would you say that
children
have received enough attention so far in
this pandemic
so far the focus of the pandemic has
been on the elderly
especially those older people over 80
years of age in particular high risk of
fatal
causes and that's why the
pandemic is a pandemic of the elderly
let's say overall
children do not have a very high risk
of becoming seriously ill and that's
probably
the explanation for the fact that
children are not in the middle of the
activities
around the pending the fight against the
pandemic
process worldwide so to answer
your question with
one sentence no children do not have
received enough attention during this
pandemic process
yeah especially now with the new
variants we see a rise in infections
among children
but why is that well um we we do not
really know what happens if uh children
are in touch with
uh sasquatch ii and the the mutations
so probably um the previously
introducted
virus is more or less similar to
a coronavirus which is more or less
frequent
in the children population now the
the mutations are something new for the
immune system and that probably one
reason why
the numbers are going up but it's not
good underst and there's not a good
understanding how
how this this works so
do we then know whether all children are
equally at risk right now or
especially those with a special
precondition
well good news is that most of the
children
do not have a very high risk to to
become seriously illness but um
there are also complicated um some
complications especially in those
children which are
risk and those children are new bonds or
preterm infants or
those with underlying diseases for
example congenital heart deficiency or
immunodeficiencies um as well as those
children which were treated with
immunocompromising medications in term
in terms of hemato oncological diseases
and so on
there is a relevant number of children
with
a high risk and one prominent a
group of diseases um the
down syndrome those children are at very
high risk
for severe and fatal outcome
um due to sask of two and other children
with
um let's say
inborn era of metabolisms or
syndromes for example like tuberose
sclerosis and others
and these children uh they react
differently mostly
to the virus than adults or elderly uh
with with inflammatory uh reactions of
various organs i mean how
worried should we be about the so-called
pims or misc
yeah this inflammatory multi system
syndrome is is not very common
so we do have observations of this
syndrome
in in hospitals especially in my
hospital
as well but the numbers are overall
um overall the numbers are though so
there is
not really a matter to worry about this
but
at least there are some children which
were affected by these pims
and there is an assumption that a
genetically
determined susceptibility um
is responsible for these cases so this
means
um it's not random that a child affects
it's predescribed by
a genetical determined susceptibility
all right professor knuff there thank
you so much for your time
so step by step we learn more about
covid19 and children
and about covet 19 in general it's time
for your questions now
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
do the different vaccines protect people
from the long-term effects of covert 19
many patients who contract covet 19
become what are known as
as long haulers or people who have
long covered there's currently no way to
predict
who that might affect although there
isn't
really an accepted definition for it
having long covid basically means you
don't return to your previous levels of
health
even months after sars kobe 2 falls
below detectable levels in your body um
it's affected millions of people who
have a wide spectrum
of of longer term symptoms with with
chronic fatigue for example
a really regular complaint um there are
two
big theories for for what might be
causing it
one is that long covet happens when the
body
can't clear out all of the virus or
viral fragments
left after infection that basically the
virus
is able to hide in some people somehow
and that the body goes into a kind of
of trench warfare mode
the second hypothesis is that long covet
is an
unchecked autoimmune response so
so an off the rails immune system
in some patients experts say it could be
a combination
of both but there's no doubt that for
people
suffering long coveted symptoms the
prospect of
getting vaccinated must be pretty
terrifying i mean could getting the shot
actually make you feel worse well
although i emphasize that we still can't
say anything for certain
there are a growing number of anecdotal
reports
that getting vaccinated appears to be
actually
helping at least some people with long
covet
we don't know why one small study and
peer review
also at least indicates that more
long haulers feel better than feel worse
after being vaccinated
the problem is to find out more we would
have to conduct
trials where some long-haulers get covet
19 vaccines and
and others get placebos masquerading as
covet-19 vaccines
um i don't think that's going to happen
to be honest
in the current climate right now i can
only say that the general consensus
seems to be
that long haulers should also be
vaccinated
and some anecdotal reports say
it might help with symptoms
[Music]
derek williams there and he'll be back
to answer more of your questions
tomorrow
that's all for now thanks for watching
stay safe
[Music]